[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend ihnen allen wir
beginnen diese sendung im weltgrößten
exportland für kohle das liegt am
anderen ende dieser erde aber was dort
geschieht betrifft auch uns es ist eben
ein planet und wir haben nur ihn die
menschen down under in australien haben
den machtwechsel gewählt premierminister
scott morrison umstritten wegen seines
harten corona kurses wegen seines harten
kurses gegen flüchtlinge er nannte sich
bulldozer umstritten auch als
unterstützer der kohlelobby er verliert
sein amt
wahlsieger ist dieser mann anthony
albanese spitzname album zum ersten mal
seit fast einem jahrzehnt eine
sozialdemokratische regierung
der neue beschreibt sich als klima
anwalt aber und damit sind wir bei der
entwicklung die eben nicht nur
australien aufwühlt er erbt ein land in
dem ausgerechnet die kohle gefragt ist
wie nie ein klimakiller der gerade jetzt
das ganz große geld bringt aus
australien normen odenthal
hunter valley new south wales
australische bilderbuchlandschaft da
vorne treiben margaux und michael weit
ihre rinder zusammen die farm ist ihr
leben aber alles steht auf der kippe nur
einen steinwurf von ihrem wiesen
entfernt wird die welt bald eine andere
sein die bagger arbeiten schon daran
aus diesem gebiet hier werden sie 50
millionen tonnen kohle herausholen
zwischen 2023 und 2029 rechtlich gesehen
haben wir keine chance die genehmigung
ist derzeit in australien sagt man wir
sind erschossen
das ist die zukunft der planet kohle die
region ist eine kraterlandschaft schon
jetzt und weitere gruben werden
erschlossen von ausstieg ist hier nicht
die rede nur von wachstum denn
australiens schwarzer schatz wird
gebraucht von china bis indien und
findet gerade immer neue abnehmer was
der industrie volle kassen beschert und
eine portion genugtuung
ich würde meinen dass viele staaten mit
blick auf die jüngsten ereignisse in
europa der ukraine die ausrichtung ihrer
energiepolitik überprüfen müssen und das
dürfte dann ganz sicher auch den
weiteren einsatz von kohle energie
schließen
wer energie aus russland nicht will
braucht andere lieferanten australiens
kohleindustrie ist ein krisengewinner
die beschäftigten auch im schnitt
verdienen arbeiter 80 bis 90 tausend
euro im jahr und die jobs scheinen
wieder sicher in der dorfkneipe herrscht
zuversicht
die kohle ist nicht am ende durch die
ukraine krise ist die nachfrage riesig
das wird ja morgen nicht vorbei sein
unsere kohle wird einfach gebraucht und
wir haben für die beste verlegt hat es
hängt ja auch viel dran so viele jobs in
den ruinen bei zulieferern die ganze
kette wenn du die kohle auf geben
würdest was dann
2050 will australien klimaneutral sein
später als andere aber immerhin die
kohle ist die größte hürde lange schon
steht sie am pranger schuldig gesprochen
für den klimawandel dessen folgen
australien zu heftig spürt
überschwemmungen buschbrände dürre doch
der ausstieg scheint wieder ferner denn
je die großen parteien scheuen sich vor
konkreten zusagen und pharma michael ist
frustriert man kann eben nicht einfach
sagen solange uns jemand die kohle
abkauft machen wir immer weiter damit
wird australien seiner globalen
verantwortung nicht gerecht und ich
werde es so meiner verantwortung auch
nicht gerecht als großvater von sechs
cent
grün oder grau wie sieht das hunter
valley von morgen aus die kohle bringt
wohlstand und vernichtet idylle es
scheint schwer dass eine zu wollen und
das andere zu bewahren
drei tornados in nordrhein-westfalen
eintrifft die innenstadt von paderborn
es waren nur minuten aber es sind bilder
die man so nicht kannte bei uns und
nicht kennen will es gab unwetterschäden
an vielen orten in deutschland nirgendwo
so stark wie im osten von nordrhein
westfalen der tag danach das große
aufräumen und für viele wird jetzt erst
klar was da passiert ist hat das parade
mit mir
das geräusch von kettensägen es ist an
diesem samstag überall zu hören in
paderborn aufräumarbeiten am tag danach
das chaos lichten die schäden
begutachten das was sich hier innerhalb
weniger minuten ereignete macht die
menschen immer noch fassungslos
ich habe aus dem fenster geguckt die
sind abgebrochen die streichhölzer
allein drei tornados wüteten gestern in
aus westfalen meldet der deutsche
wetterdienst die zerstörerische kraft
überrascht viele auf dem parkplatz einer
corona teststation in paderborn bangen
die insassen im auto um ihr leben kräfte
die die spitze dieses kirchturms
wegreißen mächte die bäume wie
streichhölzer umknicken
wetterphänomene dieser extremen
ausprägungen könnten nach meinung von
meteorologen auch durch den klimawandel
begünstigt werden wir müssen sagen dass
im zuge des klimawandels es sowieso viel
extremere unwetter gibt und in solchen
extremeren unwetter ist prinzipiell auch
mehr potenzial für heftige tornados
trotzdem gibt es nicht bei jedem
unwetter tornado gefahr zum beispiel bei
den gewittern die wir am montag erwarten
ist die tornado gefahr sehr gering
43 verletzte und sachschaden in
millionenhöhe
es wird wochen monate dauern bis alle
schäden beseitigt sind was bleibt ist
unsicherheit denn eine solche
katastrophe hat man hier in paderborn
noch nicht erlebt
das wochenende soll wettertechnisch
ruhig bleiben ab montag sind dann neue
gewitter vorhergesagt
nach der wahl ist vor der wahl alter
polit spruch und wie alle alten polit
sprüche natürlich war die letzten beiden
landtagswahlen waren enttäuschend für
die spd bei der nächsten steht jetzt
zudem ein eigener ministerpräsident auf
dem spiel gut ist es noch ein paar
monate hin bis niedersachsen wählt aber
der ehemalige hannoversche ehrenbürger
gerhard schröder macht der partei gerade
in seiner heimat noch andere sorgen
heute war der bundeskanzler in
niedersachsen bei den wahlkämpfenden
genossen peter kunz mit mehr dazu
sturm wochenende in deutschland und ein
sturm fester olaf scholz unterwegs
sturmfest so nennen sich die
niedersachsen olaf scholz ist einer von
geburt getauften schon in hamburg
rückenwind aus berlin will er stephan
weil mitbringen der als nächster für die
spd in einen landtagswahlkampf zieht von
form blasen dem kanzler zwei verlorene
wahlen und bröckelnde umfragewerte für
die sozialdemokraten ins gesicht wir
haben dieses jahr drei bahn gehabt in
einem fall ist es uns gelungen von platz
zwei auf platz 1 zu kommen und einen
regierungswechsel zu berichten bei den
anderen beiden malen hat der schwung
dafür nicht gereicht aber das ist für
uns nur die grundlage das zu tun was
jetzt notwendig ist notwendig ist
ballast abzuwerfen der putin angestellte
und niedersachsen gerhard schröder darf
diesen beiden sturm festen nicht mehr in
die quere kommen ich stephan wahl
übrigens auch wir beide haben schon
lange gesagt gerd schröder soll diese
posten aufgeben und in dem zur kenntnis
dass es jetzt bei einem passiert und die
anderen müssen auch noch folgen gerd
schröder steht gegenwärtig
ausschließlich für sich
für die niedersächsische spd war der
genosse oder früher kein kandidat der
herzen aber dem kanzler scholz hat man
sich jetzt wohl angenähert ich glaube es
ist nicht immer ganz glücklich mir
kommuniziert da bin ich ganz dabei aber
das wasser macht da stehe ich voll
dahinter manche leute mögen als
politiker vielleicht eher den den den
jahrmarkt redner sage ich mal andere
leute bevorzugen eher so ein bisschen
die ja die besondere darstellung die
besondere politik und dafür steht
sicherlich olaf scholz und ich bin
absolut überzeugt davon dass ruhe um
sich die zeit auch zum nachdenken und
zum abwählen genau dass es was in diesen
zeiten die große mehrheit der menschen
in deutschland habe olaf du stehst
michael
unbeirrt bei sich bleiben prinzip scholz
den niedersachsen erklärte der oft
erklärungs foul gescholtene
bundeskanzler heute was er unter
sturmfest versteht wenn ein sturm auf
den nächsten folgt pandemie ukraine
sozialer sprengstoff durch inflation wir
haben am freitag im bundestag und im
bundesrat die gesetzgebung zu ende
gekriegt für eine 30 milliarden schwere
entlastung
und die hilft mit einmalzahlung für
diejenigen die wenig geld haben
zufriedenheit der basis mit der führung
das war in der spd langerak aber die
partei ist auch von der zeitenwende
erfasst sie ist ein kanzlerwahlverein
geworben
scholz und weil auf einem plakat wird es
für die niedersachsen war am 9 oktober
trotzdem nicht geben da bleibt die
arbeitsteilung und und land
der eine hat so was wie feierabend die
linkspartei ist ebenfalls mit wein
nachlese beschäftigt nur dass es dort
mittlerweile ganz grundsätzlich an die
substanz geht ja mitten in der krise hat
die bundesvorsitzende der linken janine
wissler angekündigt erneut als
parteichefin zu kandidieren ende juni
soll auf dem bundesparteitag der linken
der komplette vorstand vorzeitig neu
gewählt werden wissler sagte sie wolle
mit ihrer kandidatur einen beitrag zur
erneuerung der linken leisten die partei
steht nach den wahlniederlagen bei den
vergangenen drei landtagswahlen und
sexismus vorwürfen massiv unter druck
im konflikt um den nato-beitritt
finnlands und schwedens hat der
türkische präsident erdogan nun mit den
regierungen beider länder telefoniert
laut ankara forderte erdogan schweden
dazu auf die unterstützung
terroristischer gruppen wie der pkk
aufzugeben und außerdem das
waffenembargo gegen die türkei zu
beenden die schwedische
ministerpräsidentin sagte nach dem
telefonat sie stehe hinter dem kampf
gegen terrorismus finnlands präsident
witterte von einem offenen gespräch am
mittwoch hatten beide länder ihre nato
beitritts anträge eingereicht die türkei
stemmt sich bisher gegen eine aufnahme
die für heute in iran geplante
hinrichtung des schwedisch iranischen
wissenschaftler samad reza jalali ist
offenbar nicht vollstreckt worden das
heute-journal von charlies ehefrau
wieder mehr anja erfuhr wolle das
iranische justiz ministerium eine
aufschiebung prüfen zudem appellierte
sie an die eu zu handeln und ihren mann
noch zu retten 2017 war jalali wegen
spionagevorwürfen von iran zum tode
verurteilt worden das un
menschenrechtskommissariat
bezeichnete die drohende hinrichtung als
willkürlichen akt
in deutschland sind zwei weitere fälle
von affen pocken entdeckt worden und
zwar in berlin der zustand der
erkrankten ist laut senatsverwaltung
stabil erst gestern war eine erste
infektion in münchen bekannt geworden
der dort der patient dort leidet an der
milch westafrikanischen variante des
virus das robert koch institut rechnet
mit weiteren fällen in deutschland aber
nicht mit einer welle von infektionen
zu den lottozahlen die lauten
134 19 30 44 superzahl 4 alle angaben
wie immer ohne gewähr
die wetteraussichten im nordosten sowie
im südwesten gibt es morgen vereinzelt
kurze schauer sonst eine meist freuten
dich hier mischung aus sonne und wolken
höchstwerte zwischen 16 grad auf rügen
und 26 grad am oberrhein
am montag bei 20 bis 27 grad im
nordosten freundlich im westen und süden
kräftige gewitter mit starkregen hagel
und sturmböen dienstag und mittwoch
wechselhaft und kühler
ja und dann gibt es heute zwei
fußballmannschaften die die chance haben
an diesem abend den größten triumph
ihrer jeweiligen vereinsgeschichte
perfekt zu machen also nicht alle beide
natürlich sondern eben nur eine das dfb
pokalfinale der sc freiburg gegen rb
leipzig die einen gelten als die
bodenständigen aus dem sonnigen
südwesten deutschlands die anderen sind
für manche immer noch eher
sportunternehmen als fußballverein 1 zu
1 nach 90 minuten dann verlängerung dann
elfmeterschießen und jetzt volker grube
voll besetztes olympiastadion in berlin
und die herzlichen glückwünsche des
ehemaligen bundestrainers löw für
freiburgs christian streich und dessen
mannschaft wirkt von beginn an sehr
entschlossen 19 minute günther sieht
schornstein steht frei und hat
torriecher und treffsicherheit 12
ein perfekter schuss aus 18 metern
bringt freiburgs führung schoss
handspiel hier wird nicht als
absichtlich gewährte treffer zählt
leipzig bäumt sich auf erhöht die
offensive unter druck macht freiburg
fehler höfers rückpass unglücklich
bringt den kongo in spieler
schlotterbeck verhindert leipzig
ausgleich die diskus mannschaft nach der
pause mit dem unbedingten willen aber
konter anfällig
köhler läuft halstenbek und der weiß
sich nicht anders zu helfen als mit
einer notbremse rote karte völlig
unzweifelhaft
freiburg versucht den knappen vorsprung
anschließend zu verwalten leipzig aber
gibt nicht auf mit dem mut der
verzweiflung rennen die zehn
verbliebenen sachsen an und nach fast
einer vergebenen möglichkeit ist es im
kongo in der 76 minute den ausgleich
schafft mit dem richtigen instinkt und
dem perfekten feingefühl
auch nach 120 minuten keine entscheidung
das elfmeterschießen
nach freiburgs kapitän christian günther
verschießt auch r medien die mimik und
damit ist bleibt sich nach zwei
verlorenen pokal spielen erstmals dfb
pokalsieger
und damit gibt es eine sehr sehr sehr
lange nacht in sachsen und die nächsten
achten gibt's hier gegen 0 uhr 45 heute
express mit ralph schippers gehen morgen
sind wir wieder für sie da und zwar sehr
gerne also auch am sonntag für heute
ihnen allen einen sehr angenehmen haben
[Musik]